right um good afternoon councillors and
i welcome you to this
special meeting of
council
just before we move on to the agenda can
we just get the protocols around
the mask wearing
correct my understanding is that unless
we're speaking uh we have masks on all
the time
is that the right um mrs jones here okay
so this was speaking
uh my song and if if you want to speak
with your mask on then that's fine
can you hear me okay
there's always one
okay so
you're welcome along to this
extraordinary meeting um we have
one apology uh
councillor grant uh councillor doug
grant who's
notified his apology some time ago
and he's sent to me today and i think he
shared it with councillors his thoughts
around three waters which we can discuss
later on
but it is a
particularly important
step in
in the process of three water reform
that we
meet today to discuss
the various options that have been put
forward to us
uh and in our response to that
now in my mind there's still a lot of
clarity that's not there that we need
before we can make any decision on
behalf of this community
but bearing that in mind we do have to
give some response to the minister by
the end of this month
so she gets a sense of
both
the good and the bad of what our
feelings
might be around the reforms that are
likely to happen in the not too distant
future
so
without any further ado i'll open up the
first item which is a report
from the chief executive which i think
really summarises very well
the process
the issues
the challenges that we face
and and also summarizes in a very clear
and concise way
some of the options going forward for us
and what we should
suggest to the minister
so um i'll move over to you steve
thanks your worship as you said the
it's very difficult when you're being
asked to give
concise views on what is an incomplete
picture in front of you
despite what is a deluge of information
that has descended upon the sector in
the last nine to twelve months
around three waters of reforms
but unfortunately there's still uh
aspects and key aspects of
the way in which these new entities will
they're proposing to establish
will
operate how they'll be governed how the
appointment process will take place and
the
bottom line or the absence of any bottom
line guarantees or any definition around
how the council might interface
effectively
with
those new entities
just to
goodness have we got a secret
okay that's fine yeah you can be
councillor mcdonald tonight dennis
that's fine
that's right
okay sorry um steve
uh so yes worship
the report hasn't been an easy one to
write been when you are
you've got those difficulties of trying
to do justice to what is a very complex
issue and have
a lot of aspects that are
ill-defined at this point in time
and
you're trying to navigate your way
through that
what i've tried to do as best like i can
is to look at the reform process through
the lens of the gore district council
and the community it serves
not to wade into the
national debate
or
jump on the train of
a popular slogan or two
and
uh
rage against the proposal
so but having said that it's it is
difficult because the options open to
the council at this point in time are
limited
uh as best as i could
discern there really only is on the
table from the government
two options and that is one is to
forge an independent path and assume the
opportunity to be part of the reform
process
or to
embrace the reform process albeit with a
lot of detail yet to
emerge
for councils to
consider
so
i guess the guts of my report
and sometimes the report has been
written on the basis that the public
would want to know how we got to this
point in time
and what the next steps are
it's not a report that recommends the
council take a decisive course of action
because that is not what a the
government wants at this point in time
and b we're not in a position to make a
decision because
uh
anything
uh two two reasons one is the incomplete
information and secondly any decision to
change the mode of service delivery with
three waters would require
consultation and at this point in time
unless there's a law change an amendment
to the ltp
i have in my report as best as i can
your worship highlighted the advantages
and disadvantages of each of the two
options and again
that's open to the council to agree or
disagree with that
i have
floated
a third option that
is
gaining some popularity around the the
traps
which is um the concept of
a the government taking on the role as
funding partners similar to what uh
waka katahi does with roading
and as i said in my report when you have
a funding partner sometimes the
insurmountable challenges become
challenges that you think yeah we can do
this
and we've proven that time and time
again in the roading area
ironically in years gone by um a lot of
this infrastructure the council has put
in place would have been with the
benefit of
government subsidy
at this point in time that has
not been put on the table
and i'm unaware of any
detailed analysis that's been
made available to anyone in the sector
about why that option could not be
pursued
because rest assured the creation of the
new water entities
will be capital intensive and i do while
not contained in my report i do wonder
at the extent of the wish slash shopping
list that communities will
have to
post to the new entities
about their their needs uh in the
water space particularly waste water
so i guess you wish at the end of my
report i'm suggesting that the
council
given the stark options might like to
convey that
it seeks further clarity around
some issues
that at this point in time
opting in
in some form or or
or
continuing on in the um discussion on
the reform process would be
more sensible for the council than
declaring that we don't want to be part
of anything
but also that there are some key things
we'd like to have discussed and we talk
about
a decent
voice
from the community to be able to
interface with the entity there is the
issue of equitable equity of funding i
find it very difficult to
believe that this community should
receive
almost only half of what a community in
the north island with a similar or less
population would receive that to me is
uh just doesn't doesn't seem fair or
right
and even allowing for different
deprivation factors it does seem to be
heavily skewed in some council's favors
favor and once again just as we found
with the incentive funding that came in
the first tranche
this council is coming off second best
and there may be will be other things
you worship that the council wants to
convey to the government but my
suggestion is
that
the council does convey its concerns in
a constructive but cautious manner
and to say that
we would
like to
carry on in the discussion with the
reform process but also i would like the
the third option of a funding
partnership to be given serious
consideration and costed against
the
what will no doubt be a massive upheaval
in the three waters area and to local
government generally
if these reforms as proposed albeit
without the vital information attached
to it
uh are implemented
thank you uh thank you steve um and as i
said before i think your report takes us
to the the nub of um the challenges that
we have before us and i'm about to open
it up for uh counsellor input into the
discussion
uh i guess just one thing i'd like to
reiterate
and there's been quite a lot of talk
about opting in and opting out
that time is not now
and and i think it just will confuse
the process and
and the the community if we talk in a
way about opting in or opting out what
the government has asked for now is our
thoughts on the process
and where we see the challenges and
where we see the opportunities so if i
could just ask you to bear that one in
mind so with that in mind i'll open up
the discussion councillor bulger
uh for those people who are watching us
by live streaming it it's a comfort to
me and should be to them that providing
feedback to central government doesn't
commit us to a certain
line of uh a course of action
um
i do take your point that you may not
wish to explore the option of opt-in and
or opting out
so the reality is um council cannot and
ratepayers cannot afford
to fund the improved
water and wastewater standard that
governments require alone we just can't
possibly do it
and so we need um we need government
support and we're deserving of
government support and so you know if
that's going to be the basis of our
feedback which is in line with the chief
executive's recommendation
that's where we should land for sure
um
i do believe that
the organisation
here in gore anyway can can do the work
but
external funding or assisting from from
central government
i believe would get things up and
running quicker may possibly be more
efficient than another
level of bureaucracy but i am reminded
and it's come out of this discussion
about reform it is not possible for us
as a
small entity to fund these
improvements
and and standards required
for just funded
um purely and simply and only by the
right path we need outside
financial support so your third option
that's the one i'd like to see
uh explore
you look you make some very good points
there and it just reminds me um and
recall
comments made by um
our recently departed infrastructure
director
ramesh when he's talking about
the future for this district and the
challenges that we face in the water
space the three-water space
that probably over the next
25 to 30 years we need to be expanding
somewhere in the order of 300 million
dollars
at current um levels of quality and and
standard so i i think that is that
really puts this discussion into context
for me
and it's not something that a community
this size
um
could take on i don't believe
am i open for further discussion council
mcphail
sure i'll get my
microphone going um through to the co
there um very good um
outline of the facts i think we've got
it all laid out there
um and having been party previously to
workshops and the many workshops around
the province
in regard to the challenge um
you know we have got an agent water
infrastructure it is going to cost us
some serious money to fix that up
there's no doubt that's fact that's
that's laid out to us at all these
but two things was a couple of things
that came out of that process
they always said that we would um
we'd get a genuine choice around how we
were going to be able to
discuss and inform that
and also there would be the community
involvement
so
at the moment
um
we're holding our cards we're really
holding what and they're holding their
cards it's a bit of a
situation where uh who who's actually
going to play the next card and i think
the central government experience
shouldn't outweigh our community's
ability um to to own a process
that that we are getting pushed along
very very quickly to make a decision
about this reform and today we obviously
have got some uh
great um information
that has been laid out in these options
um
you can't do a jigsaw without all the
pieces and
that's what we're looking at um
you just can't do it so
we need to have the reform fully
explained and where we're going to lie
the options of opting out completely
you know that could be a generational
issue along with um opting in completely
and that'll that'll weigh on our
community so i think that we are being
quite appropriate about going back under
that option three going back and
indicating we want to um
more information also outlining uh
possible possibly some
proposals there
um
really the key aspects too many unknowns
the decision is probably
too too big to be made
on the
information that we currently have
thank you richard and you make a good
point in terms of
timing and and i think the chief
executive uses in his report being
shepherded into a place where we need to
make a decision uh in a in a quite a
fast manner
but just for me for clarity and for
information for those that might be
watching the stream steve can i ask you
just in terms of timing
the 30th of september is when we need to
give feedback
and
when we get to a point where assuming
that it's still viable opting in or
opting out uh happens by the end of the
year is that right
yes that's correct do you worship and i
further understand that the government
will give some
uh indication of um its timetable
sometime in october following this
feedback
great thank you
okay uh any other counsellors want to
make any comment at this point in time
councillor heisted
yeah thanks your worship um
yeah obviously financially the gorgeous
council needs assistance cliff summed it
up really well and i guess the report
from the chief executive has spot on is
this the best model
we certainly haven't been given a wide
range of options
but what doesn't change is who pays and
it's going to be the rate payer
and whether that's through through debt
or aggregation um you know our ability
to raise debt is is very limited so
um
governance um has been raised a few
times there with 21 councils in n2td
four cities
and so that leaves uh 17
other councils
looking for seats and there's only six
seats so i think that connection to the
community
connection to this council and
governance and and someone said in a
recent zoo meeting when there's a
problem with the water who's going to
get the call and who's going to be held
accountable and how connected are we to
those you know to be able to effect
change to the community so i agree with
the um the report and the options given
by the chief executive
and yeah just but
that does serve the local voice and our
role in governance and influence
thank you councillor i guess
that community voice is one of the the
major things that i have in my mind and
the last thing we want to see happen is
that
we get this entity sent up and there is
a um
a call center somewhere
in the north island or offshore uh where
you you've got to make your um
request known i feel sure that won't
happen but it is possible um anything's
possible into the future
so that is a major concern in my mind i
guess the other one is the local
servicing
and making sure that we've got capacity
stationed in this community to do what
uh the guys that are there now do and do
it to the same uh standard
so yeah both those points are well made
glennis
thank you worship
um i agree with the other councillors
and their comments and the options given
in a very good report
i just have a question around the um
inequality between
group a
and group d which is um
our group
that in
2051 that's going to be costing us is
supposedly costing us sixteen hundred
and forty dollars
per um
extra and it'll cost um auckland eight
hundred dollars
so the water care group in auckland has
a 1.3 billion whole and capital which is
included in group a has a 90 million
dollar rate payed debt
and i realize there's economies of scale
here but auckland has far more debt and
they have far more storm water and far
more waste water so it seems as if some
equalities there that need to be dealt
with as well the population based
funding never ever
fits well with southland and it always
seems to be detrimental to us
and i also wonder about the
debt
funding the debt
as i believe that
local government funding agency rules
prevent lending
to anybody other than councils so which
would mean that the debt cannot be
transferred
to the four new authorities
so i'm
wondering if that needs to be clarified
as well
i saw that point made um in the last few
days i like i believe there would be a
method for
paying off that debt and transferring it
that wouldn't that i don't believe that
would be a showstopper at all
however
you raise some other issues in the terms
of the
the differences between the four
entities in terms of cost both now and
into the future and i think it simply
does come down to sheer scale but do you
want to make a comment to that one steve
yeshua you are right it is down to sheer
scale and
one of the
one of the options that has never been
canvas for example is if you're going to
reform
why wouldn't you even look at having
just one entity for the whole country to
get real economies of scale because
one of the
the downsides of four entities is that
you'll have to have four sets of um
specialist engineers four it systems
four hr systems four
ces four
and there's not enough capacity in the
country now um but i mean it's only a
personal view but if you go to reform
once it leaves this district is there
any difference if it's in christchurch
or if it's in wellington or auckland
if there's pricing
that can be secured that makes it more
advantageous once again i think that's
an option that's worthy of consideration
should the big reform process march on
forward
okay uh other councils council guard on
you know i do um agree with steve
if you're going to have a new identity
you might also have one for the whole
country
and
also what needs simplified in this
system
is the governance there's no ability for
the consumer to be able to touch get to
the directors directly
um which is probably needs to be looked
at i think a lot of other councils have
pointed that out
if you look back at the other option of
having a similar system with subsidy
like the um
transport system
it did work in the 80s a lot of water
schemes and sewage schemes
were set up with a one-to-one subsidy
and if you work through our problem of
300 million
if we had a one-to-one subsidy over 30
years we could deal with our problems
and deal with it
we may need outside technical advice
which we do now but we having a
central government system for technical
advice and
standard sort of planning for projects
of wastewater and water would be handy
so there is could be a hybrid system
come out of this whole thing
but if the government pushes ahead and
mandates that we all go in i would
advocate that we probably should have a
one one
company for the whole of new zealand
and that the um
we could cut some further costs out of
the management
and also
in the technical side
and also with the
one company for new zealand i think it
would be a fairer system
it'll be evened out
if you take for example the pair at the
moment the south island probably
subsidizes pear going to the north
island
and we pay higher rates down here and
share the transmission costs
with the north island whereas
this water thing will be the other way
around they will reciprocity
thank you
yeah look again um all councils are
making some some very good points and i
think what you've said john
just um emphasizes and backs up
the sense that we have seen and and i'm
sure a number of other councils see it
uh around the wakatakatowi
model it
it gives
shared buy-in both from a central
government perspective and a local
government perspective but it also
addresses that very key issue in my mind
which is the the community voice
so
we live in those communities that are
going to be serviced
and every one of the councillors is um
very accessible to the
the the people that are being serviced
so um you can't get a better model in my
mind than than that one however that
will be traversed i guess as time goes
on
thanks
uh other nikki thank you yeah thank you
worship um i agree that we need to be
looking at
the third option as well
makes the most sense to me
what concerns me if we go to
four entities is will they all be
singing off the same hymn sheet is there
going to be
differences throughout the country in
different standards throughout the
country and that concerns me because
we should all be under the same
standards
and i think you've got the potential or
the risk anyway if if you go to four
entities that they'll do to do things
differently so
i would question whether we need four i
think we need one
and uh i would support option three as
well
okay i think
you know
i'll go along with
the option of one
one entity in terms of the standards i i
think that that's been covered off
pretty well actually
and
for the first time in at least 50 years
we've got a regulator in tomato roi that
will
actually enforce the regulations so
i guess the the way you get to a
particular end point
probably will it might vary a bit
between the various entities but the the
water that's delivered at the end uh to
the consumer
uh and taken away and and going into the
river or to the land will have to be at
a particular standard and if you don't
reach that standard
then there will be a big cost go with
that
councillor hosted
thanks just the point of clarification
is that feedback to government around
one entity or about an alternative model
i believe
that there's two two purposes crossing
here and we could we could confuse the
issue if we
say
modify to one entity but we're looking
for an alternative model
and just while i'm speaking there was
one very good point made in the chief
executive's report around staff you know
the character and structure of the
organization a small council such as and
many others are reliant on the engineers
and the senior managers
to run our total organisation and while
there's an acknowledgment of stranded
overheads that's an ongoing unwind of
the of the organization and its ability
to deliver in an efficient manner which
i don't think would ever recover
on a uh on a option one or four entity
model
yeah
you do raise some uh very good points
brett and and we do need to be very
clear about what we're saying here um
uh in terms of the ability of the
organisation to perform if we take
a fair chunk of capacity out of it
is is a concern to to everyone
and when you consider the reforms that
are going on multiple fronts
particularly the three water one but but
also the whole
planning and
regulations
the likelihood that
a lot of the engineering type
specialist services
may well
be taken away from from councils as we
know them
and and i acknowledge that the
government have set up
a forum which is looking at
the future for local government and
and and i understand that there are
opportunities that that we can look at
uh that may well
give us more scope and more
uh ability to connect stronger with our
community on on various issues as
opposed to delivering hard services like
water delivery and roading however
that running after the other two reforms
i don't believe is the right order of
things and and it's problematic
so it does smack a little bit of um
not making it up on the hoof but getting
things out of sync uh a wee bit
that nibble
thank you your worship
right from the start i
voted against this and was very cautious
about what was going to happen
i sit here in
looking after
the
wishes of the district and the right
power
who will probably end up paying a lot
more than what they really think
i wait cautiously to see what
comes out of this report and i think
the chief executive for his report in
bringing through a few ideas that we had
discussed in one of our workshops
and i like i like to report we need to
be tough for the government because it's
been forced upon us
and we've got no clear answers yet so
how can we make a formal decision yet
and i think that we just have to a wait
and see
approach
and
have the what is the best outcome for a
rate payer and like councillor garden
a debt reduction
cannot be um put through with with the
money that we're going to receive
and how do we recover the cost of the
debt that's already rich that we already
have
now
with with no rights coming in from from
no raiding from it so that's another
question that he has to be asked
so um just to reiterate
we're not asking for a decision this is
not asking us to make a decision now
this is asking us to give us our
feedback on what we see before us
in terms of debt my understanding is
that any debt that relates to a
three-water asset will transfer out of
us anyway so
the responsibility for maintaining and
delivering services
would transfer but so too would the debt
that has gone with that over the last
few years
council guard on
the only trouble would be his other debt
our debts have um hung on a one 1.75 of
their gross income
three waters is quite a chunk of their
gross income
how does it marry up with their other
debt is there a match over
and if there is really we need more debt
reduction than just the three waters
um
i can't answer that question um
do you want to make any comment
i i couldn't really worship um would
need to do that analysis um i just
thought off top and head i couldn't do
it but your council got on raises a good
point
that
your revenue falls and therefore the
percentage
that you can raise against that revenue
falls with it
but having said that your worship
the
if three waters did leave the council's
care
arguably a lot of your exposure to high
risk projects would also go with it
particularly when you've got uh you've
tucked away some of the big ticket items
like the library
uh your multisports complex this
building um
off the top of my head you wouldn't have
the same kind of exposure to
large
unknown costs projects and costs
before you
okay uh council bulger
yeah
we're raising questions the chief
executive cannot answer you know i'm not
sure the thief and central government
can answer at this at this point so you
know from my own mind i have to take it
back and keep it fairly simple and look
again at the recommendation and
particularly the point that giving
feedback doesn't commit us to any action
one way or the other that's important
point but the last paragraph and the
recommendation
and i'll read it and the council
provides feedback to the minister of
local government based on the
conclusions reached
uh and subsequent raised by council and
section 11 of the report and that
basically as i read it is to explore the
chief executive's suggestion
that a third option of collaboration uh
with central government under the
uh
uh would be
what we would like to see explored a
little further and and you know to that
ian i'm happy to rem to move that
recommendation
thank you um is there a seconder for
that motion uh councillor davis so
before i put that motion are there any
other counselors that want to make a
comment i know that um as i mentioned at
the beginning i had a a note from
council
grant
who obviously can't vote in this
particular issue because he's not here
but would like his feelings shared so
i'm more than happy to
to do that now
um
hi tracy um can i have my apology
please for the extraordinary council
meeting uh with regard to three waters
reform i'm away uh working for this week
um
we as councillors of the gore district
council find ourselves in one hell of a
situation regarding the three waters
reforms government which i believe is
trying to force through in an
unacceptable time frame
we know the heblock north tragic
circumstances regarding drinking water
triggered this knee-jerk reaction
we see before ourselves today you can't
tie
the entire
new zealand district with one brush
because of an incident in one urban
drinking water supplier
i acknowledge the standards have to
change for cultural and well-being of
all new zealanders and also the climate
change has its parts to play now don't
get me wrong uh gore district hasn't
kept up
with all the drinking water regulations
and that have come thick and fast out of
wellington but we've tried
with the amount of money that's possible
to leverage from the rate powers before
lynching begins
we do have an acceptable ltp plan in
place which doesn't break our
self-imposed braiding cap we are
woefully behind with our storm water and
wastewater separation but horizontal
infrastructure has been neglected for
years especially in a small rating
district like ourselves because of
affordability
and none of a central government help
so now this government wants to help us
with a 9.15 million payout which has
conditions associated to the package of
funding yet to be worked through
available in 2024
and taking all our and taking all
control of what happens to our water
away from us
because they know better and can save up
to 50 of the costs nationwide
sounds like a two-year you're right
this whole three-waters reform i think
is lacking in detail and
and with threats
so i believe i could be wrong that if
the entire local bodies up and down the
country don't join the scheme it'll be
forced upon ourselves
and being made by mandatory by this
government
that that my fellow councillors could
constitute bullying i believe
um
i don't believe i have a law degree
that my fellow councillors could
constitute bullying although i don't
have a law degree to confirm that
i agree with the possible
recommendations that the ce has put
forward especially
that we could have a funding package
similar to
waka katahi
or nzta or some not
where
for instance we could receive say 10
million dollars a year for the next 30
years that will give us the cash flow
and the workforce we have in place to
steadily fix our own three waters issues
be in charge of our own destiny not
signing up signing it over to an entity
we don't know how it is run the makeup
of
the makeup and whom could sell it off to
in the future to be privatised like the
pair companies have so my please is to
send the government some alternative
ideas that our community
with
in the gore district come up with a
funding solution to part and partnership
with central government
so people can retain control and
the knowledge of its rewarders
yet working digitally towards cleaning
it up and to try and meet regulations
handed down by future governments uh
within a boundary of common sense thank
you councillor uh south councillor grant
okay um other councillor heisted
you think sure
i just have a problem with the
recommendation because it refers to
um
clause 11 which
at 11.3 covers three concerns we have
around the existing model and then
touches on the nzta solution
you know as i said it earlier is this
council saying on one hand tweak the
model in front of us
um but consider
the nzta model are we going to push
hardback and say we believe the nzt a
model was
is a more appropriate pathway
because i just see
one is quite supportive the other one's
on a tangent
sorry i'm an alternative view which i
support the nzta option
um i understand we're going to confu
confuse
the issue and say well we're sort of
supportive but on the other hand maybe
not
okay do you want to make comment to that
yes you wish i'm not i'm not really at
the council's um direction here but the
intent was well the government said
here here's uh what we're thinking we
want your feedback
and i've just i've distilled it to two
options
uh
neither of which um
have
universal attraction because of the
uncertainties associated with it and
some of my concerns in my report
so i flirted the third option of wakaka
katahi
i think it was we discussed at a
workshop the option the notion was along
the lines world
will give
the government some feedback on what
it's tabled but also ask that they give
serious consideration to a third option
which it has up until now
refused to budge and refused to even
disclose any evaluation that may have
made
in
rejecting that option
so i envisaged that the feedback would
would include
the council preference for
independence
as um
as a supplier of of three waters with
the government as a funding partner
but also say
um
at the same time
based on what you've revealed to date
these are our views in terms of if you
were still
minded to proceed with the reforms
these are the concerns we have with it
that's that's my interpretation of how
we will approach it but you could
frame
the
proposed letter which his worship would
sign
a different way you could
say well
we think that the only viable option is
the the
the
waka kotahi equivalent
and leave it at that um
or again you could say well that's our
preference but you know based on what
you've you've the hand you've revealed
these are our concerns and this is our
feedback
but i appreciate that and i couldn't
attend the workshop i guess i put my rma
commissioner head on when you are often
presented that from from a submitter um
you don't really like what you're doing
um
but suggestion that it could be
acceptable if you do thus less than
that's and i just hope that air our
litter is sufficiently
focused on
the alternative that's only my personal
yeah yeah and just on that point um
we've got the item before us um
that
that whole item may well go to the the
minister but there will be a letter that
will
encompass everything that we
believe should happen going from here as
well
steve cliff
i think what we're saying is
we're not saying no to central
government we're not waving away the
need for reform
we're not throwing in those at central
government but we're just not
satisfied with the proposal
uh we'll consider it but we're not
satisfied with the proposal that they've
set in front of us and you know the
recommendation is a partnership along
the lines of
wakatobi
basically you know i think it's pretty
simple
we can do the work we just need the
money
that's right yeah and
that same message
i know will be coming from a number of
other councils uh up and down the
country
okay um council going on
the only problem with the transport one
is our issue is where does the funding
come from at the moment the transport is
quite simple it comes from road users
and petrol tax
the government have said well where does
the money come from well
it'll have to come from taxpayers
or be a long-term loan to the users
spread over a long period to be able to
work
one way or the other there's going to
have to be a partnership between
communities
and end users as well as
central government
and i guess just how that partnership is
structured is the is the key thing so
there is a good balance and people feel
as though they're they've still got
input and and um skin in the game
but not
paying through the nose as well
okay um so
we have a motion uh and as i said before
i envisage and i'll just get the chief
executive to
confirm that that from here
in the next day or two we'll construct
a letter
to
to go to the minister
which will encompass
everything that's in the report
along with uh
the points that have been made uh during
this discussion today is that right
let's correct your worship yes the
letter is due with the minister by
friday the 1st of october
okay
right if there's nothing further i'm
going to put that motion
um
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried uh thank
you councillors and look i i think that
is a very good response on behalf of
this community a very responsible
response
there is a problem that has to be
addressed
and and while
the medicine that we've been
delivered to this point is not that
agreeable
i think there is a lot to be gained by
working
collaboratively with
our local government partners but also
central government partners to get to a
point
where at least we might have some common
ground so so thank you for that
okay we have one other item on this
agenda which is uh general insurance
update
uh are you gonna
do you want to speak to this steve
and we have a report here from
uh tears watson
yeah thank you worship um uh lorna
strafe unfortunately is an apology today
she's got a day's leave and she's chosen
a superb day to have that days leave i
might add
this this is our annual insurance
renewal we worship um normally it would
go to
audit and risk
for approval uh but because of lockdown
and a postponement order and risk
meeting
and that the insurance renewal has to
be affected before the expiry of the
current policy on 30 september
we need to present it to you for
hopefully approval uh talking will
launch she's very happy with the pricing
um
given that
in recent times there's been quite some
hefty spikes in insurance
so the
the net increase of thirteen thousand
dollars we think is reasonably modest um
given uh say the recent uh last two
years experience
um
and it's providing us with stability and
the
we must say and lorna has said to me
that she's been very impressed with the
efforts of our broker and if it's their
mate to
look after us
so
really just we would i'd certainly
endorse your recommendation that
hopefully you can approve the
new premiums
and the recommendations contained within
the broker's report
for us to sign up another year's worth
of protection
thank you
as chair of ordinance brett do you want
to make
um any comment on this one
thanks worship um
yeah i think it would be useful to um
ask mr chamberlain their independent
member of work risk to to review it or
not not to hold up the renewal but but
to have the ability to go through it
because he um
he feeds on these sorts of things and
there's good good points to offer i
guess my only question is around
increased value
on assets that were simply refurbished
you know are we are we really needing to
increase cover but that's that's
probably a discussion for next year's
renewal we need to get on and do this
and ensure the assets are covered okay
so with that in mind is someone prepared
to move the motion uh incorporating the
uh so i moved council high state
signature council guideline um that we
accept the recommendation uh
on the understanding that
our independent member of the audit and
risk will get the opportunity to review
it as well
okay unless there's any other question
i'll put that motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors um like i think that brings
us to the end of this particular meeting
and and
and i think we're getting to the
the pointy end of a very important
process um not just for this council but
for the
for the nation um
and
uh it's going to be interesting to see
where we go from here and what sort of
response we get from central government
hopefully it's a listening year
and they
are prepared to work with us because i
think there is a very strong will up and
down the country
for a local government to work
collaboratively with central government
and
we all have skin in the game we have a
community that needs
and deserves clean fresh water
and excellent wastewater disposal
and
we need to get that done as soon as we
possibly can so without any further ado
i'll declare the meeting closed and
thank you councillors for your input and
your attendance thank you